the time of emancipation Charlottesville
and the surrounding area was majority
black and you don't see that narrative
by having Confederate monuments standing
in the center of parks towering over
whole communities what you see is you
see a romanticized version of the South
you see um memorabilia that makes people
feel good about the Civil War but it
doesn't tell the story of the South
losing it doesn't tell the story of the
Confederacy she says the monument was
supposed to make people feel good about
the Civil War what is that what you
think monuments are meant to do nobody
feels good about the Civil War what do
you mean feels good about it what would
have you ever heard that opinion
expressed what do you think about the
Civil War oh yeah I felt great about it
I feel really great I'm happy so I feel
good that doesn't even make any sense G
monuments don't exist to make us feel
good about uh the wars that they are
remembering but they do exist to
remember because these are events that
we should remember